With the Fizz loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fizz.ca. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website.
通过Fizz忠诚度计划，您只需拥有一个移动套餐即可获得奖励。比如发短信之类的。如果您现在的移动套餐没有提供额外流量和现金折扣等奖励，那您用的就不是Fizz。今天就换用Fizz吧。受条件限制，详情请见fizz.ca。我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用内或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。
This episode was originally released on Casefile's Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and ad-free, you can support Casefile on your preferred platform. On the evening of Tuesday, May 10 1994, staff at a home on Granno Street in the regional Victorian town of Ararat served up dinner at the usual time of 6pm. The home was a residential care unit for people with disabilities. The unit's five inhabitants were cared for around the clock
本集最初发布在Casefile的Patreon、Apple Premium和Spotify Premium订阅源上，作为我们付费订阅者的早期福利。这些剧集旨在缩短时长，以便我们涵盖更广泛的案例。要提前收听这些剧集并享受无广告体验，您可以在您偏好的平台上支持Casefile。1994年5月10日星期二晚上，维多利亚州阿拉拉特镇Granno街一家住所的工作人员在通常的下午6点准时供应晚餐。该住所是一家为残疾人提供的居住护理机构。该机构的五名住户全天候受到照顾。
by live-in staff from the Department of Health and Community Services. It was their job to support and empower the residents to live as independently as possible. But as the staff and residents gathered around the dining table to eat their dinner together, one chair remained empty. The cheerful and gentle fifth resident of the unit, 41-year-old Lindsay Jellett, was nowhere to be seen. Lindsay Jellet was a creature of habit. Shortly before 4 o'clock that afternoon, he asked the staff at Grano Street for permission to go for his daily walk. This was Lindsay's favourite part of the day, the only time he was free and unrestricted. Although it was rare for Lindsay to be late, he loved food and his carers
由卫生与社区服务部的工作人员提供住家护理。他们的工作是支持并赋能住户，让他们尽可能独立地生活。但当工作人员和住户聚集在餐桌旁共进晚餐时，有一把椅子仍然空着。该机构第五位开朗而温和的住户，41岁的林赛·杰莱特（Lindsay Jellett）不见踪影。林赛·杰莱特是一个习惯成自然的人。那天下午4点前不久，他向Grano街的工作人员请假去进行日常散步。这是林赛一天中最喜欢的时光，也是他唯一自由且不受限制的时候。虽然林赛很少迟到，但他热爱食物，他的护理人员
were sure he'd be back before long. They put his plague in the microwave so they could reheat his dinner as soon as he showed up. But by 6.30 there was still no sign of Lindsay. His carers checked his bedroom and the backyard in case he'd returned without them noticing. One of the staff drove around the streets on the lookout but had no luck finding him. By seven o'clock, they were really worried. It was dark and cold outside and Lindsay had never come home this late. The police were promptly called. Lindsay was last seen by Grano Street staff at 3.45pm as he set off for his afternoon walk. While a traumatic head injury at the age of two had left Lindsay with cognitive disability
确信他很快就会回来。他们把他的餐盘放进微波炉，这样他一出现就能加热晚餐。但到了6点30分，仍然没有林赛的踪影。他的护理人员检查了他的卧室和后院，以防他回来而他们没注意到。其中一名工作人员开车在街上寻找，但没能找到他。到了7点，他们真的担心了。外面又黑又冷，林赛从来没有这么晚回家。警方随即接到报警。林赛最后一次被Grano街的工作人员看到是在下午3点45分，当时他出发去进行下午的散步。虽然两岁时的一次创伤性头部损伤导致林赛患有认知障碍
and developmental delays, he was more than capable of navigating his daily routine. He could shower, feed and dress himself. He couldn't read or write, but he could communicate coherently, count to 30, and knew the value of money to $10. Lindsay particularly loved walking to a nearby golf course where he'd collect lost golf balls and bring them home to clean and give to his friends. His other favourite walk was to the main street of town. Lindsay had a sweet tooth and he'd spend his $5 daily allowance on cigarettes, coffee, Coca-Cola and biscuits. One of his legs was shorter than the other, so he tended to shuffle along slowly, often stopping to talk to people in the
和发育迟缓，但他完全有能力处理日常事务。他可以自己洗澡、吃饭和穿衣。他不会读写，但能连贯地交流，能数到30，并且知道10美元以内的钱币价值。林赛特别喜欢走到附近的一个高尔夫球场，在那里他会收集丢失的高尔夫球，带回家清洗后送给朋友。他另一个喜欢的散步路线是去镇上的主街。林赛喜欢吃甜食，他会把每天5美元的零花钱花在香烟、咖啡、可口可乐和饼干上。他的一条腿比另一条短，所以他走路时往往会缓慢地拖着脚，经常停下来与街上的人交谈。
streets. In the first few months of living at Granow Street, Lindsay walked so much that he wore out several pairs of shoes. He walked for hours each day, but was always home in time for dinner. With Lindsay now failing to return home, time was of the essence. It was a frosty, rainy night and he was ill-prepared for the weather, having left home in just a pair of trousers and a blue fleece top. Adding to the urgency was the fact that at 8 o'clock each night, Lindsay took the drug Tegretol to treat his epilepsy. A missed dose could put him at risk of a seizure. As luck would have it, the Ararat branch of the State Emergency Service were in the middle of a training session and could be deployed immediately to help police with the search.
在住在Grano街的最初几个月里，林赛走得太多，以至于穿坏了好几双鞋。他每天走几个小时，但总是能赶在晚餐前回家。由于林赛现在没能回家，时间至关重要。那是一个寒冷多雨的夜晚，他没有为天气做好准备，出门时只穿了一条长裤和一件蓝色抓绒上衣。更紧迫的是，林赛每天晚上8点都要服用泰格瑞托（Tegretol）来治疗癫痫。漏服一次可能会让他面临癫痫发作的风险。幸运的是，州紧急服务中心（SES）阿拉拉特分部当时正在进行培训，可以立即部署协助警方搜寻。
They were advised that Lindsay was timid and there was a possibility he might hide if approached by someone he didn't know. Search units scoured the town by car and on foot, with the SES truck driving slowly along the back roads using a search light to sweep the surrounding paddocks and farms. Sheds and outbuildings were checked in case Lindsay was seeking shelter from the bad weather. But he was nowhere to be found. The following morning of Wednesday May 11, police narrowed in on Lindsay's home. They rechecked the residence and the surrounding area just in case he'd returned and was too frightened to come inside because he knew he was late.
他们被告知林赛性格胆小，如果遇到陌生人可能会躲起来。搜寻小组开车和步行搜遍了全镇，SES卡车沿着后路缓慢行驶，使用探照灯扫视周围的围场和农场。棚屋和附属建筑也被检查过，以防林赛在躲避恶劣天气。但他无处可寻。次日，即5月11日星期三上午，警方将搜寻范围缩小到林赛的家。他们重新检查了住所及周边地区，以防他已经回来，但因为知道自己迟到了而不敢进屋。
Yet there was still no sign of him. All available crews from police stations in neighbouring towns joined the search, with the air wing dispatched to search overhead. With no reports coming in about a lost or disorientated man, police contacted all the local radio stations to broadcast Lindsay's details so the entire community would know to keep a lookout. A local farmer heard the reports and set on a drive around the roads that boarded his property. As he made his way along Down Road, a dirt stretch roughly two kilometres northeast of Lindsay Jellett's home, the farmer saw what looked like a white running shoe on the grassy verge at the side of the road. He kept going, but the image of the shoe worried him. He did a U-turn and drove back towards it. As he approached, he realised there were actually two
然而，依然没有他的踪影。来自邻近城镇警察局的所有可用人员都加入了搜寻，空中联队也被派往空中进行搜索。由于没有关于失踪或迷路男子的报告，警方联系了所有当地广播电台播放林赛的详细信息，以便整个社区都知道要留意。一位当地农民听到了报道，开车绕着他房产周边的道路行驶。当他沿着Down路行驶时，那是一条位于林赛·杰莱特家东北约两公里的土路，这位农民看到路边的草地上似乎有一只白色跑鞋。他继续前行，但那只鞋的画面让他感到不安。他掉头开车回去。当他靠近时，他意识到实际上有两只
shoes. The farmer pulled over on the opposite side of the road and got out of his car. Lying on the grassy verge was the body of Lindsay Jellett. Lindsay's blue fleecy top was pulled up, exposing his thin white torso, which was stained with a liver-coloured patch of congealed blood under the skin. His eyes and mouth were half open, his left cheek grazed, and his nose unnaturally bent. While his belt was still buckled, it had been melted apart on the left hand side. His white running shoes were still on his feet, but the right one was crushed, its sole bursting from torn stitching. one was crushed, its soul bursting from torn stitching. Three packets of cigarettes and a cigarette tin lay next to his body with a five dollar bill discarded at his right elbow.
鞋。这位农民在马路对面靠边停车，下了车。躺在草地上的是林赛·杰莱特的尸体。林赛的蓝色抓绒上衣被掀起，露出了他瘦弱的白色躯干，皮下有一块肝色的凝血斑。他的眼睛和嘴巴半张着，左脸颊有擦伤，鼻子呈现不自然的弯曲。虽然他的皮带仍然扣着，但在左侧已经被熔断。他脚上仍然穿着那双白色跑鞋，但右边的那只被压扁了，鞋底因缝线撕裂而爆开。他的尸体旁放着三包香烟和一个烟盒，右肘旁丢弃着一张五美元的钞票。
Nearby was an empty beer can. It appeared as though Lindsay Jellett had been struck by a car. Not only were there obvious crush injuries to his legs and torso, tyre tracks in the dirt road led straight to his body. But as soon as the crash investigators arrived from Melbourne, they knew this wasn't a standard hit and run. There are six elements that correlate with this type of impact. The first three are injuries to the shins, hip and head, as the victim strikes the vehicle's bumper bar, bonnet and windscreen or roof. Then there's the scene itself. Blood from the victim, as well as some trace of the car involved, such as broken glass or paint flakes, are expected to be found. The sixth element is that the victim is usually
附近有一个空的啤酒罐。看起来林赛·杰莱特是被车撞了。不仅他的腿部和躯干有明显的挤压伤，土路上的轮胎痕迹也直接通向他的尸体。但当来自墨尔本的事故调查员到达后，他们知道这不是一起普通的肇事逃逸。这类撞击通常有六个要素。前三个是胫骨、臀部和头部的损伤，因为受害者会撞击车辆的保险杠、引擎盖和挡风玻璃或车顶。然后是现场本身。预计会发现受害者的血液，以及涉及车辆的某些痕迹，例如碎玻璃或油漆碎片。第六个要素是受害者通常
shoeless. It is a little known phenomenon, but when people are hit by cars they are generally knocked clean out of their footwear. In fact, the crash investigators had never attended a hit and run where the victim was still wearing shoes. A cursory examination of the scene showed that none of the six elements were present. Furthermore, Lindsay's body was arranged too neatly by the side of the road. If he'd been hit by a car while walking, his body would have been flung and landed awkwardly. His top being pulled up also indicated that someone had gripped him under the arms and dragged him along. This was supported by marks in the road, with two parallel lines appearing to have been made by the
没穿鞋。这是一个鲜为人知的现象，但当人们被车撞时，他们通常会被撞得鞋子脱落。事实上，事故调查员从未处理过受害者仍穿着鞋子的肇事逃逸案件。对现场的粗略检查显示，这六个要素都不存在。此外，林赛的尸体在路边摆放得太整齐了。如果他在走路时被车撞，他的尸体会被抛出并以尴尬的姿势落地。他的上衣被掀起也表明有人抓住他的腋下把他拖行了一段距离。路上的痕迹支持了这一点，两条平行的线条似乎是由
heels of Lindsay's shoes. Lindsay might not have been hit by a car, but from his injuries it was obvious that he had indeed been run over. He had abdominal bruising consistent with a car tyre and the lower parts of his legs had severe crush injuries. There were smears of grease on his body and clothing as well as burn marks where he'd come into contact with the hot exhaust section underneath a vehicle. Yet, the lack of blood at the crime scene intrigued investigators. This indicated that Lindsay was already dead when his body was run over. A lack of bleeding confirmed this theory. Marks in the dirt showed that Lindsay had most likely been dumped from a vehicle before being dragged to the side of the road and then run over on the verge. Fibres consistent with his trousers were found near the drag marks,
林赛鞋子的后跟造成的。林赛可能不是被车撞的，但从他的伤势来看，很明显他确实被车碾压过。他的腹部有与汽车轮胎相符的淤青，腿部下半部分有严重的挤压伤。他的身体和衣服上有油脂污渍，还有与车辆下方炽热排气管接触造成的烧伤痕迹。然而，犯罪现场缺乏血迹引起了调查人员的兴趣。这表明林赛在被车碾压时已经死亡。缺乏出血证实了这一理论。泥土中的痕迹显示，林赛很可能是从车上被抛下，然后被拖到路边，最后在路边被碾压。在他的裤子纤维附近发现了与他裤子一致的纤维，
and there were acceleration scuff marks alongside his body. The resulting spray of gravel coupled with the tyre tracks indicated that a vehicle had reversed to where Lindsay's body lay and then backed right over him, twice. After running over Lindsay, the car then turned around and headed in the direction of Ararat. The pathologist conducting Lindsay's autopsy couldn't determine what had caused his death. Given Lindsay's history of epilepsy, she considered a syndrome known as sudden unexpected death in epilepsy or SUDEP. This is where an otherwise healthy person with epilepsy dies prematurely, typically in their sleep. In cases of SUDEP, a post-mortem examination shows no cause of death. Sometimes there are signs that a seizure has occurred,
他的尸体旁有加速留下的擦痕。由此产生的碎石喷溅加上轮胎痕迹表明，一辆车倒车到了林赛尸体所在的地方，然后直接从他身上倒车碾过，碾了两次。在碾过林赛后，车子掉头朝阿拉拉特方向驶去。负责林赛尸检的病理学家无法确定他的死因。鉴于林赛的癫痫病史，她考虑了一种被称为癫痫猝死（SUDEP）的综合征。这是一种患有癫痫的健康人在睡眠中过早死亡的情况。在SUDEP病例中，尸检显示不出死因。有时会有癫痫发作的迹象，
such as the individual losing control of their bladder, but Lindsay's autopsy showed that his bladder was full. Furthermore, if Lindsay had died from SUDEP, it didn't explain why someone would drag him to the side of the road and run him over with a car. Crash investigators sought to identify the type of car that had run Lindsay over. The owner of a local tyre shop agreed to accompany police to the scene. Upon seeing the tracks, he was certain they'd been made by Bridgestone Eager S340 tyres. Smears of red fluid on Lindsay's white running shoes were suspected by one investigator to be automatic transmission fluid. If he was correct, this meant police were looking for an automatic car, probably an older model which would be more likely to leak.
例如个人失去对膀胱的控制，但林赛的尸检显示他的膀胱是满的。此外，如果林赛死于SUDEP，这无法解释为什么有人会把他拖到路边并用汽车碾压他。事故调查员试图确定碾压林赛的车辆类型。当地一家轮胎店的老板同意陪同警方前往现场。看到痕迹后，他确信这些痕迹是由普利司通（Bridgestone）Eager S340轮胎造成的。一名调查员怀疑林赛白色跑鞋上的红色液体污渍是自动变速箱油。如果他是对的，这意味着警方正在寻找一辆自动挡汽车，很可能是一款更容易漏油的旧车型。
Leaking transmission fluid didn't necessarily drip out. Instead, it formed a film over the car's transmission pan located in its undercarriage. The fluid could have been transferred to Lindsay's shoes when the car ran over him. The fact that Lindsay's body was smeared with black grease also suggested an older car. Slowly but surely a picture of the wanted vehicle emerged, an automatic, older-style car with Bridgestone Eager S340 tyres. If the vehicle had left traces on Lindsay, then he'd likely left traces on the vehicle. The only problem was that the evidence would largely be underneath the car, rather than obvious visible damage to the car's exterior.
泄漏的变速箱油并不一定会滴出来。相反，它会在车辆底盘的变速箱油底壳上形成一层油膜。当车子碾过林赛时，液体可能转移到了他的鞋子上。林赛身上沾有黑色油脂的事实也暗示这是一辆旧车。一幅目标车辆的画像逐渐清晰起来：一辆带有普利司通Eager S340轮胎的自动挡旧式汽车。如果车辆在林赛身上留下了痕迹，那么他很可能也在车辆上留下了痕迹。唯一的问题是，证据很可能在车底，而不是车身外部明显的可见损伤。
Detectives began looking into Lindsay's life for clues as to who could be responsible. By all accounts, Lindsay Jellett was a harmless and friendly man who was well known and well liked in his community. The more the detectives learnt about Lindsay, the harder it was to imagine why anyone would want to kill him. They did a door knock of the houses surrounding Lindsay's, many of which housed residents with disabilities, but no one had a bad thing to say about him. On the afternoon that Lindsay's body was discovered, a roadblock was organised on Granow Street for the same period of time that Lindsay went missing,
侦探们开始调查林赛的生活，寻找谁可能负责的线索。据各方描述，林赛·杰莱特是一个无害且友善的人，在社区里广为人知且深受喜爱。侦探们对林赛了解得越多，就越难想象为什么会有人想杀他。他们对林赛家周围的房屋进行了走访，其中许多房屋住着残疾人，但没有人对他说过一句坏话。在发现林赛尸体的当天下午，警方在Grano街组织了一个路障，时间段与林赛失踪的时间相同，
with detectives stopping all cars to ask if anyone had seen Lindsay walking the previous day. cars to ask if anyone had seen Lindsay walking the previous day. Greno Street is one thoroughfare through Ararat and 4pm is a change of shift time for workers for the local prison and railway as well as health and community services staff. One man stopped at the roadblock knew Lindsay by sight. He told detectives that at around 4pm the day before, he'd seen Lindsay climbing into a car that was parallel parked to the curb a short distance away from his house. It was an older model brown coloured sedan with a red LPG gas sticker on its number plate. The man had caught a glimpse of the driver. It was a middle-aged woman with dark hair who he
侦探们拦下所有车辆，询问是否有人在前一天看到林赛走路。Greno街是穿过阿拉拉特的一条通道，下午4点是当地监狱、铁路以及卫生和社区服务人员的换班时间。在路障处被拦下的一名男子凭外貌认识林赛。他告诉侦探，前一天下午4点左右，他看到林赛爬进了一辆平行停在路边、离他家不远的车里。那是一辆旧款棕色轿车，车牌上有红色的LPG燃气贴纸。那名男子瞥见了司机。那是一个深色头发的中年妇女，他
didn't recognise. This description immediately gave investigators pause. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. and dollars off with your mobile plan. You're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply, details at fizz.ca. Give the perfect gift that keeps on giving, an Aura Frame. It's one that friends and family are sure to love and has been named the best digital photo frame by Wirecutter. Aura Frames come with a vivid HD display,
不认识。这一描述立即让调查人员停顿下来。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。以及您的移动套餐现金折扣。那您用的就不是Fizz。今天就换用Fizz吧。受条件限制，详情请见fizz.ca。赠送一份完美的礼物，一份Aura相框。这是朋友和家人一定会喜欢的礼物，并被Wirecutter评为最佳数码相框。Aura相框配有生动的高清显示屏，
unlimited storage, and the ability to preload the frame with photos and videos. Right now you can get $25 off Aura's best-selling Carver Matte Frames by using promo code ACAST. Just visit AuraFrames.com. That's AuraFrames.com promo code ACAST. Conditions apply. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. In 1955, when Lindsay Jellar was two and a half years old, his mother was pushing him and his twin sister along in a pram. As she edged the pram out between
无限存储空间，并能够预装照片和视频。现在，您可以使用促销代码ACAST购买Aura最畅销的Carver Matte相框，立减25美元。只需访问AuraFrames.com。即AuraFrames.com，促销代码ACAST。受条件限制。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。1955年，当林赛·杰莱特两岁半时，他的母亲推着婴儿车带着他和他的双胞胎妹妹。当她把婴儿车推到
two parked cars, a truck suddenly struck the front of it. The force of the collision threw Lindsay heavily onto the road. While his twin sister Judith was unhurt, Lindsay suffered severe brain damage and was in a coma for nine weeks. By the time he was finally allowed to return home from the hospital, his behaviour had changed significantly and his parents struggled to control him. He was eventually diagnosed with epilepsy and an intellectual disability. When Lindsay was seven, his parents made the difficult decision to place him in a living care facility. They visited him often, and he was occasionally allowed home. In time, Lindsay grew into a gentle and loving man.
两辆停放的汽车之间时，一辆卡车突然撞上了婴儿车的前部。碰撞的力度将林赛重重地抛到了路上。虽然他的双胞胎妹妹朱迪思（Judith）没有受伤，但林赛遭受了严重的脑损伤，并昏迷了九周。当他最终获准从医院回家时，他的行为发生了显著变化，他的父母难以控制他。他最终被诊断出患有癫痫和智力障碍。林赛七岁时，他的父母做出了一个艰难的决定，将他安置在一家生活护理机构。他们经常去看望他，他偶尔被允许回家。随着时间的推移，林赛成长为一个温柔而充满爱心的男人。
He'd pick flowers from the garden to give to visitors, and was always quick with a hug and a joke. When Lindsay's parents passed away, his twin sister Judith became his closest living relative. Even though she had her own health problems and priorities in life, Judith always made time to visit her brother. She'd often take her four children with her, making the four hour round trip to Ararat from their home in the suburb of Melton. They take Lindsay out to lunch or to visit a museum or park. Judith bought Lindsay clothes and anything else he needed, treating him to chocolate, lollies and sweet drinks. While the drive there and back with a car full of kids was
他会从花园里摘花送给访客，总是很快就能给人一个拥抱并开个玩笑。当林赛的父母去世后，他的双胞胎妹妹朱迪思成了他最亲近的在世亲属。尽管她自己也有健康问题和生活重心，但朱迪思总是抽出时间去看望她的哥哥。她经常带着她的四个孩子，从他们位于梅尔顿（Melton）郊区的家出发，往返四个小时前往阿拉拉特。他们带林赛出去吃午饭，或者去参观博物馆或公园。朱迪思给林赛买衣服和任何他需要的东西，请他吃巧克力、糖果和甜饮料。虽然带着一车孩子往返的旅程
gruelling, it was never a chore. A friend of Judith said she had more patience, love and understanding for Lindsay than she did for her own children. In late 1993, the facility that Lindsay had lived in for 20 years was shut down as part of the Victorian government's commitment to move residents from institutions into the community. Lindsay made the move to the Greno Street residential unit, where Judith continued to visit every month or so. On Tuesday May 10 1994, Judith scheduled a one o'clock meeting with Greno Street staff,
非常艰苦，但这从来不是一件苦差事。朱迪思的一位朋友说，她对林赛的耐心、爱心和理解比对她自己的孩子还要多。1993年底，林赛居住了20年的机构作为维多利亚州政府将住户从机构转移到社区的承诺的一部分而关闭。林赛搬到了Greno街的居住单元，朱迪思继续每月左右去探望一次。1994年5月10日星期二，朱迪思安排了与Greno街工作人员在一点钟的会面，
followed by a three o'clock meeting with support staff from a nearby organisation that ran a day program Lindsay attended. She did this every so often to check how her brother was doing. Judith picked Lindsay up at 11.30am, then took him to the Ararat RSL to play the pokies. After having lunch together, they headed to Lindsay's Grano Street unit for their one o'clock meeting. The staff told Judith that her brother's epilepsy was under control, but that he should avoid beer in case it triggered a seizure. Beer wasn't really an issue with Lindsay. He mainly drank coffee or coke.
随后在三点钟与附近一家运营林赛参加的日间项目的组织的支持人员会面。她经常这样做，以检查她哥哥的情况。朱迪思在上午11点30分接上林赛，然后带他去阿拉拉特RSL玩老虎机。一起吃过午饭后，他们前往林赛的Grano街单元进行一点钟的会面。工作人员告诉朱迪思，她哥哥的癫痫得到了控制，但他应该避免喝啤酒，以防诱发癫痫发作。啤酒对林赛来说并不是什么大问题。他主要喝咖啡或可乐。
With an hour to kill before their next appointment, Judith took Lindsay to the shops to buy him a couple of things. Then they attended their 3pm meeting, after which Judith dropped Lindsay back at Grano Street at around 3.40. She bid Lindsay goodbye, just as he was preparing for his afternoon walk. Before leaving, Judith left some treats in her brother's bedroom for him to enjoy later. When Lindsay was reported missing later that evening, his carers attempted to call Judith at her home in Melton, but there was no answer. They left her a message and she called them back at 8pm. They informed to Judith that Lindsay hadn't returned home after his walk. She shared their concerns but offered a simple explanation.
在下一次预约前还有一个小时，朱迪思带林赛去商店给他买了几样东西。然后他们参加了下午3点的会议，之后朱迪思在下午3点40分左右把林赛送回了Grano街。她向林赛告别，当时他正准备去下午散步。离开前，朱迪思在哥哥的卧室里留下了一些零食供他稍后享用。当林赛当天晚上晚些时候被报告失踪时，他的护理人员试图给住在梅尔顿的朱迪思打电话，但没有人接听。他们给她留了言，她在晚上8点回了电话。他们通知朱迪思林赛散步后没有回家。她分享了他们的担忧，但提供了一个简单的解释。
She'd given Lindsay $25 that afternoon. It might have been possible that he was spending it in town. Fifteen minutes later, Judith called back having just remembered a significant incident. Years prior, Lindsay had run away and was found wandering down a highway into Melbourne en route to Judith's home. She recommended that the search party keep an eye out for him on the outskirts of town and along the railway lines, before asking if it was raining. Her voice was tinged with worry when she remarked, He doesn't have his coat with him. When Lindsay was found to dead, detectives paid Judith a visit in Melton. Having already been delivered the news, she was visibly upset,
她那天下午给了林赛25美元。他可能是在镇上花钱。十五分钟后，朱迪思回电，刚刚想起了一件重要的事情。几年前，林赛曾离家出走，被发现沿着高速公路走向墨尔本，前往朱迪思的家。她建议搜寻队在镇郊和铁路线沿线留意他，然后询问是否在下雨。当她评论道“他没带外套”时，她的声音中带着担忧。当林赛被发现死亡时，侦探们拜访了梅尔顿的朱迪思。在已经收到消息后，她明显很不安，
but she managed to tell the detectives about her final encounter with her brother the afternoon prior. She detailed their lunch, errands, and meetings before recalling one notable moment. While in town, Judith ducked into a pharmacy, leaving Lindsay waiting outside. When she came out, Lindsay was talking to a woman parked in a battered old van. He told her that he'd just won money at the pokies. To the detectives, this was a solid lead. Could Lindsay have been targeted by someone who thought he might be in possession of some winnings. Wondering whether drugs or alcohol could have also played a role in Lindsay's death, the
但她还是设法告诉了侦探她前一天下午与哥哥的最后一次见面。她详细描述了他们的午餐、跑腿和会议，然后回忆起一个值得注意的时刻。在镇上时，朱迪思溜进了一家药店，让林赛在外面等。当她出来时，林赛正在和一个停在破旧旧货车里的女人说话。他告诉她，他刚在老虎机上赢了钱。对侦探来说，这是一个可靠的线索。林赛是否被认为他可能拥有一些奖金的人盯上了？想知道毒品或酒精是否也在林赛的死亡中发挥了作用，
detectives asked Judith about the medications her brother had been taking. As far as Judith knew, the only thing Lindsay took was his anti-seizure medication, Tegretol. In regards to the beer can found near Lindsay's body, Judith said she didn't think her brother really drank beer. He had done so on occasion, but it left him sleepy. But there was one incident that raised Judith's concerns. A few months earlier, Lindsay had been visiting Judith when she ducked across the road to visit a neighbour. When she came back, Lindsay said he was tired and didn't feel well. He went to lay down, telling his sister he was having a fit. She took his pulse, but it was normal.
侦探们询问了朱迪思关于她哥哥一直在服用的药物。据朱迪思所知，林赛服用的唯一东西是他的抗癫痫药物泰格瑞托。关于在林赛尸体附近发现的啤酒罐，朱迪思说她认为她哥哥并不真正喝啤酒。他偶尔会喝，但这会让他昏昏欲睡。但有一件事引起了朱迪思的担忧。几个月前，林赛去探望朱迪思时，她穿过马路去拜访邻居。当她回来时，林赛说他累了，感觉不舒服。他去躺下，告诉他姐姐他正在发作。她摸了他的脉搏，但很正常。
Judith called one of Lindsay's carers who advised her to roll him onto his side, but by this time Lindsay appeared to be sleeping. The carer assured Judith he was probably fine, but when he wouldn't wake up after 20 minutes, Judith called an ambulance. After the paramedics took him away, Judith noticed a drawer had been opened in her bedroom, and she wondered if Lindsay had taken some of her medication. Judith suffered from chronic back pain and a litany of other health problems, for which she kept a wide assortment of medication in her home. Detectives had noticed this for themselves, as hundreds of bottles of medicine lined her shelves.
朱迪思给林赛的一位护理人员打了电话，对方建议她把他翻到侧卧，但此时林赛看起来像是在睡觉。护理人员向朱迪思保证他可能没事，但当他20分钟后还没醒来时，朱迪思叫了救护车。在医护人员把他带走后，朱迪思注意到她卧室里的一个抽屉被打开了，她怀疑林赛是否拿了她的一些药物。朱迪思患有慢性背痛和一系列其他健康问题，为此她在家里存放了各种各样的药物。侦探们自己也注意到了这一点，因为她的架子上摆满了数百瓶药物。
had noticed this for themselves as hundreds of bottles of medicine lined her shelves. Judith said she'd rang the hospital and shared her suspicion that Lindsay might have taken Valium or painkillers. The doctors gave him an antidote for Valium, after which he was fine. For detectives, this was another interesting lead. They wondered if Lindsay had a habit of taking medication that didn't belong to him. Judith told the detectives that on Tuesday May 10, she left Grano Street just as Lindsay set off for his afternoon walk and she didn't see him again after that. But detectives were curious about this. The witness who claimed to have seen Lindsay climbing into a car at 4pm a short distance from his house had described the driver as looking
自己也注意到了这一点，因为她的架子上摆满了数百瓶药物。朱迪思说她给医院打了电话，分享了她怀疑林赛可能服用了安定（Valium）或止痛药的猜测。医生给了他安定解毒剂，之后他就没事了。对侦探来说，这是另一个有趣的线索。他们想知道林赛是否有服用不属于他的药物的习惯。朱迪思告诉侦探，5月10日星期二，她在林赛出发去下午散步时离开了Grano街，之后就再没见过他。但侦探们对此感到好奇。那名声称在下午4点看到林赛爬进一辆离他家不远的车里的目击者曾描述司机看起来
exactly like Judith. The car they'd described, an older model brown coloured sedan with a red LPG sticker on its number plate, also looked just like her vehicle. Detectives had given Judith's car a once over when they saw it parked in her driveway. It was a two-tone brown 1982 Ford Fairmont Ghia sedan with a red sticker on the number plate to show that the car had been converted to gas. It also had Bridgestone Ega S340 tyres, the same type identified at the crime scene. A cursory look over the vehicle revealed no obvious fresh dance or signs of recent damage. Judith told the detectives that on the drive home from visiting Lindsay, her car overheated and she had to park by the
和朱迪思一模一样。他们描述的车，一辆带有红色LPG贴纸的旧款棕色轿车，看起来也和她的车一模一样。侦探们在看到朱迪思的车停在车道上时，曾对它进行过一次检查。那是一辆双色棕色的1982年福特费尔蒙（Fairmont）Ghia轿车，车牌上有红色贴纸，显示该车已改装为燃气动力。它还装有普利司通Eager S340轮胎，与犯罪现场识别出的类型相同。对车辆的粗略检查显示没有明显的撞击痕迹或近期损坏的迹象。朱迪思告诉侦探，在从探望林赛回家的路上，她的车过热了，她不得不把车停在
side of the road for 30 or 40 minutes while the engine cooled down. She arrived back in Melton at 7.20pm. After collecting her young children from the babysitter, Judith drove to the local petrol station, filled her car and took it through a car wash. She said she always did this after visiting Lindsay. This was another red flag for detectives. The trip that should have taken just over two hours had taken Judith three hours and twenty minutes. Not only was Judith the last person to have seen her brother alive, there was an unaccounted for period of time in her journey home. Police impounded Judith's car and took it to the Forensic Science Centre for a thorough examination. As was expected of a car that age, the undercarriage was covered
路边30或40分钟，等发动机冷却下来。她于晚上7点20分回到梅尔顿。在从保姆那里接回年幼的孩子后，朱迪思开车去了当地的加油站，加满了油并去洗了车。她说她每次探望林赛后都会这样做。这对侦探来说是另一个危险信号。本应只需两个多小时的行程，朱迪思却花了三个小时二十分钟。朱迪思不仅是最后一个见到她哥哥活着的人，而且她的回家旅程中还有一段无法解释的时间。警方扣押了朱迪思的车，并将其带到法医科学中心进行彻底检查。正如那个车龄的汽车所预期的那样，底盘上覆盖着
in dirt, grease and oil, plenty of sources that could have caused the smears on Lindsay's body. The automatic pan was also leaking and covered in a film of automatic transmission fluid. Near the front and rear driver's side wheels, examiners found spots of blood. Caught in a screw head and in various other sections of the undercarriage were fabric fibres. Several fabric impressions were also visible in the grease and dirt from the front end to the rear, and a burn mark on the engine pipe was consistent with the melting of Lindsay's belt. Police had no doubt about it. This was the car used to run over Lindsay Jellard.
泥土、油脂和机油，这些都是可能导致林赛身上污渍的来源。自动变速箱油底壳也在漏油，并覆盖着一层自动变速箱油膜。在前后驾驶员侧车轮附近，检查人员发现了血迹。卡在螺丝头和底盘的其他各个部分的是织物纤维。在从前端到后端的油脂和污垢中还可以看到几个织物压痕，发动机管上的烧伤痕迹与林赛皮带的熔化情况一致。警方对此毫无疑问。这就是用来碾压林赛·杰莱特的车。
Although this was concrete evidence that tied Judith to the crime scene, Lindsay's autopsy revealed he'd already been dead at the time he was run over. Therefore, it didn't necessarily mean that Judith had killed him. Detectives began examining Judith's timeline from the day her brother had died, starting with the pharmacy in Ararat she already told them she'd visited. Enquiries revealed Judith had filled a prescription for Rehipnol, a powerful sedative only offered to those with severe insomnia. With the postmortem proving that Lindsay was dead before he was run over, detectives wondered whether his sister could have poisoned him
虽然这是将朱迪思与犯罪现场联系起来的具体证据，但林赛的尸检显示他在被碾压时已经死亡。因此，这并不一定意味着朱迪思杀了他。侦探们开始检查朱迪思从她哥哥去世那天的行程，从她已经告诉他们的阿拉拉特药店开始。调查显示，朱迪思曾填写了一份瑞替普兰（Rehipnol）的处方，这是一种强效镇静剂，只提供给患有严重失眠症的人。由于尸检证明林赛在被碾压前已经死亡，侦探们想知道他的姐姐是否可能用
with an overdose. The contents of Lindsay's stomach showed that he was killed within 60 to 90 minutes of eating a substantial meal. Due to digestion, it wasn't possible to tell what he'd eaten. Judith said she'd taken Lindsay to lunch around midday and then for ice cream around 2pm. However, the food in his stomach could only have been consumed after leaving for his walk. Police canvassed eateries in town, but no one remembered seeing Lindsay at that time. It was possible Judith had given him some food herself. Had she done so, as soon as Lindsay got in the car, his time of death could have been as early as 5.30pm. When the results of Lindsay's toxicology tests came back, they showed two drugs were found in
过量药物毒死了他。林赛胃里的内容物显示，他在吃了一顿丰盛的饭后60到90分钟内死亡。由于消化作用，无法判断他吃了什么。朱迪思说她带林赛在中午左右吃了午饭，然后在下午2点左右吃了冰淇淋。然而，他胃里的食物只能是在他出发散步后才食用的。警方在镇上的餐馆进行了走访，但没有人记得当时看到过林赛。朱迪思可能自己给了他一些食物。如果她这样做了，那么林赛一上车，他的死亡时间可能早在下午5点30分。当林赛的毒理学测试结果出来时，显示他的体内发现了两种药物。
his system. The first was his anti-seizure medication, Tegretol, which was as expected. But surprisingly, the other wasn't Rehipnol. It was Noctek. Noctek is the commercial name given to chloral hydrate, a powerful hypnotic prescribed by doctors to treat insomnia or calm patients before a surgical procedure. It can be dangerous because the treatment dose is close to the toxic dose. The problem was that the amount found in Lindsay's system was listed as a therapeutic dose. In other words, there was not enough in his system to kill him. The amount found in Lindsay's system was listed as a therapeutic dose. In other words, there was not enough in his system to kill him.
第一种是他的抗癫痫药物泰格瑞托，这是预料之中的。但令人惊讶的是，另一种不是瑞替普兰。而是Noctek。Noctek是水合氯醛的商品名，这是一种强效催眠药，由医生开具用于治疗失眠或在手术前镇静患者。它可能很危险，因为治疗剂量接近中毒剂量。问题是，在林赛体内发现的量被列为治疗剂量。换句话说，他体内的量不足以杀死他。在林赛体内发现的量被列为治疗剂量。换句话说，他体内的量不足以杀死他。
The detectives wondered if the Noctek could have reacted with the Tegretol Lindsay was taking for his epilepsy. Medical advice suggested that these two drugs should not be taken together. Small traces of alcohol were also found in Lindsay's system, another substance that shouldn't be mixed with these medications. Detectives wondered whether the combination of Tegretol, alcohol and Noctek could have been toxic. And if Judith was responsible, did she give her brother alcohol on purpose only hours after his carers told her it could cause a seizure? To make things more complicated, it couldn't be said with certainty
侦探们想知道Noctek是否可能与林赛为治疗癫痫而服用的泰格瑞托发生了反应。医疗建议表明这两种药物不应同时服用。在林赛体内还发现了微量的酒精，这是另一种不应与这些药物混合使用的物质。侦探们想知道泰格瑞托、酒精和Noctek的组合是否可能具有毒性。如果朱迪思对此负责，她是否在护理人员告诉她酒精可能导致癫痫发作的几个小时后，故意给她哥哥喝了酒？让事情变得更复杂的是，无法确定
that Lindsay had consumed alcohol. When bodies begin to decompose, they produce alcohol as part of the natural decomposition process. The empty beer can found near Lindsay's body was tested, but it revealed no traces of Noctek or any other drugs. Enquiries at Grano Street showed no residents were prescribed Noctek, meaning Lindsay couldn't have accessed the drug at home. Detectives asked local pharmacists to go back through their records, but there had been no prescriptions written for Noctek in the last two years. There was little chance Lindsay could have come upon their drug by accident. Police confiscated hundreds of bottles of medication
林赛是否饮用了酒精。当尸体开始腐烂时，它们会产生酒精作为自然分解过程的一部分。在林赛尸体附近发现的空啤酒罐经过了测试，但没有发现Noctek或任何其他药物的痕迹。Grano街的调查显示没有住户被开具Noctek处方，这意味着林赛不可能在家里接触到这种药物。侦探们要求当地药剂师回顾他们的记录，但在过去两年中没有开具过Noctek的处方。林赛几乎不可能偶然得到这种药物。警方没收了数百瓶药物
from Judith's home, but found no sign of Noctek. They drove across town and visited medical clinics near where Judith used to live. One doctor recalled prescribing Noctek to one of Judith's children five years earlier when they were having trouble sleeping. The police visited local pharmacies and found the chemist who had dispensed the Noctek prescription to Judith. It was the break they were looking for. Now they had the proof that Judith filled a prescription for Noctek and even though it wasn't found in her house, it was clear from the volume of medications scattered all around that she didn't throw anything away. The detectives theorised that Judith could
从朱迪思的家中，但没有发现Noctek的踪迹。他们开车穿过城镇，拜访了朱迪思曾经居住附近的医疗诊所。一位医生回忆起五年前在朱迪思的一个孩子睡眠困难时曾给他们开过Noctek。警方走访了当地药店，找到了为朱迪思配制Noctek处方的药剂师。这是他们一直在寻找的突破口。现在他们有了朱迪思填写Noctek处方的证据，尽管在她的房子里没有发现它，但从散落在各处的药物数量来看，很明显她什么都没有扔掉。侦探们推测朱迪思可能
have given her brother food or drink laced with Noctek and waited until he passed out. She could have then smothered him with something soft like a pillow which would have left no trace. An eminent forensic pathologist also said that the Noctek combined with Lindsay's Tegretol could have stopped him breathing. Then, either to make it look like an accident, or to make sure she'd finished the job, she ran him over. Twice. Although this seemed like a solid theory, without hard evidence detectives knew they'd have a hard time proceeding with charges against Judith. Yet one major question still remained. Judith appeared to be a loving sister who had always been there for her twin brother. What reason could she have to want Lindsay dead?
给她的哥哥喂了掺有Noctek的食物或饮料，并等到他昏迷。然后她可能用枕头之类的柔软东西闷死了他，这不会留下任何痕迹。一位著名的法医病理学家也表示，Noctek与林赛的泰格瑞托结合可能导致他停止呼吸。然后，为了让它看起来像一场意外，或者为了确保她完成了任务，她碾压了他。两次。虽然这看起来是一个可靠的理论，但没有确凿的证据，侦探们知道他们很难对朱迪思提起指控。然而，一个主要问题仍然存在。朱迪思看起来是一个一直陪伴在她双胞胎哥哥身边的充满爱心的姐姐。她有什么理由想让林赛死呢？
Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. With the Fizz loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fizz.ca. Give the perfect gift that keeps on giving.
Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。通过Fizz忠诚度计划，您只需拥有一个移动套餐即可获得奖励。比如发短信之类的。如果您现在的移动套餐没有提供额外流量和现金折扣等奖励，那您用的就不是Fizz。今天就换用Fizz吧。受条件限制，详情请见fizz.ca。赠送一份完美的礼物，一份源源不断的礼物。
An Aura Frame. It's one that friends and family are sure to love and has been named the best digital photo frame by Wirecutter. Aura Frames come with a vivid HD display, unlimited storage, and the ability to preload the frame with photos and videos. Right now you can get $25 off Aura's best selling Carver Mac Frames by using promo code ACAST.
一个Aura相框。这是朋友和家人一定会喜欢的礼物，并被Wirecutter评为最佳数码相框。Aura相框配有生动的高清显示屏，无限存储空间，并能够预装照片和视频。现在，您可以使用促销代码ACAST购买Aura最畅销的Carver Matte相框，立减25美元。
Just visit AuraFrames.com. That's A-U-R-A-Frames.com promo code ACAST. Conditions apply. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Speaking with staff at Lindsay's Granno Street Unit, a motive emerged. Two years after the accident that irreversibly changed the course of Lindsay's life forever, the truck driver who hit the pram faced court. The judge took pity on the plight of the Jellet family and awarded Lindsay 15,000 pounds. At the time, that was a small fortune,
只需访问AuraFrames.com。即A-U-R-A-Frames.com，促销代码ACAST。受条件限制。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。与林赛Granno街单元的工作人员交谈时，一个动机浮出水面。在导致林赛人生轨迹永远改变的那场事故发生两年后，撞击婴儿车的卡车司机出庭受审。法官同情杰莱特一家的困境，判给林赛15,000英镑。在当时，那是一笔小财富，
enough to buy four or five houses. The judge ordered that the money be invested for Lindsay's future use. By 1994, the original award of 15,000 pounds had grown into a significant nest egg in excess of $120,000. An examination of Lindsay's financial records revealed that in recent years his trust fund balance had dropped from $128,000 to $107,000. This depletion was due to the fact that Lindsay had moved out of government care and had bought into the Grano Street unit. A clerk from the trust fund had written a letter to Judith, explaining, "...I have recently reviewed Lindsay's file and have noted a rapid depletion of his funds, particularly in the past six months. This rate of depletion is such that the capital is eroding and will continue to do so even if his funds only make payment of the service charge and household expenses for Grano Street.
足够买四五栋房子。法官下令将这笔钱投资用于林赛的未来。到1994年，最初的15,000英镑奖金已经增长为超过120,000美元的巨额积蓄。对林赛财务记录的审查显示，近年来他的信托基金余额已从128,000美元降至107,000美元。这种消耗是因为林赛搬出了政府护理机构，并买入了Grano街的单元。信托基金的一名职员曾写信给朱迪思，解释道：“……我最近审查了林赛的档案，注意到他的资金消耗迅速，特别是在过去六个月里。这种消耗速度使得资本正在流失，即使他的资金仅用于支付Grano街的服务费和家庭开支，这种情况也将持续下去。”
I have enclosed a financial statement which shows the expenditure for the previous seven months. Could you please contact me at your earliest convenience to discuss this matter?" Detectives contacted the clerk who said that Judith had complained in response. She said that she visited Lindsay every five to six weeks, during which she was forced to buy him everything he wanted using money from his account. If she didn't, Judith said that Lindsay became very aggressive and would steal instead. Judith told the clerk that Lindsay's demands had become worse since he'd moved to Greno Street and that was why her requests for reimbursements
我附上了一份财务报表，显示了过去七个月的支出。您能尽快联系我讨论此事吗？”侦探联系了那位职员，职员说朱迪丝对此表示不满。她说她每五到六周去看望一次林赛，期间她被迫用林赛账户里的钱给他买他想要的一切。朱迪丝说，如果她不这样做，林赛就会变得非常有攻击性，甚至会去偷东西。朱迪丝告诉职员，自从林赛搬到格雷诺街后，他的要求变得越来越过分，这就是她报销请求大幅增加的原因。
had drastically increased. With dire predictions about Lindsay's rapidly depleting trust fund, the clerk's memo was dated three weeks before Lindsay was killed. With Lindsay's death, his money would pass to his next of kin. His sister, Judith. Although the forensic examination of Judith's car proved this was the vehicle that ran Lindsay over, it didn't prove that she was behind the wheel at the time. Detectives set out to discover if anyone else had access to the vehicle. Judith stopped cooperating with the police, but she told family and friends she had her own suspicions about who was responsible. After arriving home from visiting Lindsay on May 10, Judith claimed that her ex-husband, Iliar Kifryuk, must have taken her car from the driveway and driven it to Ararat.
随着对林赛迅速枯竭的信托基金的严峻预测，职员的备忘录日期是在林赛遇害前三周。林赛死后，他的钱将传给他的近亲，也就是他的妹妹朱迪丝。尽管对朱迪丝汽车的法医鉴定证明这辆车就是碾压林赛的那辆，但这并不能证明当时是她在开车。侦探们开始调查是否还有其他人可以使用这辆车。朱迪丝停止了与警方的合作，但她告诉家人和朋友，她对谁该负责有自己的怀疑。朱迪丝声称，5月10日从林赛那里回家后，她的前夫伊利亚尔·基弗留克一定是从车道上开走了她的车，并把它开到了阿拉拉特。
Police went to speak with Iliar, who explained that he'd met Judith six years earlier after migrating to Australia from Romania in 1987. The pair married a year later and he moved in with Judith, but it was an odd arrangement. As soon as Iliar moved in, Judith told her older son, Greg, to move out. Greg began sleeping in his car in the front yard of the house. A week later, social security stopped Judith's pension payments so she told Iliar he would have to move out again. Iliar knew Judith was still seeing her ex-husband. She had retained his surname, Gengiz, but when she told Iliar she was pregnant, he accepted responsibility when she said the child was his. They split up shortly after the child was born, but Iliar agreed to pay child support of $183 per week. Iliar didn't understand the Australian court system, so he signed any papers Judith gave
警方去和伊利亚尔谈话，他解释说，他在1987年从罗马尼亚移民到澳大利亚后，于六年前认识了朱迪丝。两人一年后结婚，他搬去和朱迪丝住，但这是一种奇怪的安排。伊利亚尔一搬进去，朱迪丝就让她的长子格雷格搬出去。格雷格开始睡在前院的车里。一周后，社会保障局停止了朱迪丝的养老金支付，所以她告诉伊利亚尔他必须再次搬走。伊利亚尔知道朱迪丝还在见她的前夫。她保留了前夫的姓氏根吉兹，但当她告诉伊利亚尔她怀孕时，她说孩子是他的，他便承担了责任。孩子出生后不久他们就分开了，但伊利亚尔同意每周支付183美元的抚养费。伊利亚尔不懂澳大利亚的法律制度，所以他签署了朱迪丝给他的任何文件，
him without question. Iliar continued to pay for anything Judith needed, but it was never enough. She rang him so often at work that his employer complained. The calls were always about money. When Iliar came to visit his child, the fridge was always bare and he would buy groceries. Judith was nice to him at Easter and Christmas so he would come over and buy all the children's gifts and stock the cupboards. Iliar claimed that on the day Lindsay went missing, he'd been sent home early from work with an infected tooth and had gone straight to the dentist for a lengthy appointment.
从不质疑。伊利亚尔继续支付朱迪丝需要的任何东西，但这永远不够。她经常在工作时打电话给他，以至于他的雇主都抱怨了。电话总是关于钱的。当伊利亚尔来看望他的孩子时，冰箱总是空的，他不得不买杂货。朱迪丝在复活节和圣诞节对他很好，这样他就会过来买所有的儿童礼物并填满橱柜。伊利亚尔声称，在林赛失踪的那天，他因为牙齿感染被提前送回家，并直接去牙医那里进行了长时间的预约。
His alibi checked out, but the police already knew there was no weight to Judith's claim that Iliar could be responsible for her brother's death. By the time she'd returned to Melton, it was 7.20pm and Lindsay had already failed to return home from his walk. By casting suspicion on Iliar, Judith inadvertently revealed a bombshell. Iliar told the detectives that four months earlier, Judith had invited him to her place for dinner. He'd felt fine at the time, but the next day he felt so sick that he spent nine days in hospital. The doctors suspected he had some type of poison in his system, but they weren't sure what type. Iliar was a bit vague on the details because Judith had been the one talking to the doctors
他的不在场证明得到了证实，但警方已经知道朱迪丝声称伊利亚尔可能对她兄弟的死负责的说法毫无根据。当她回到梅尔顿时，已经是晚上7点20分，林赛已经没有从散步中回家。通过对伊利亚尔表示怀疑，朱迪丝无意中透露了一个重磅炸弹。伊利亚尔告诉侦探，四个月前，朱迪丝邀请他去她家吃晚饭。他当时感觉很好，但第二天他感觉非常不舒服，以至于在医院住了九天。医生怀疑他的系统里有某种毒药，但不确定是什么类型。伊利亚尔对细节有点模糊，因为是朱迪丝在代表他与医生交谈，
on his behalf. Now speaking to the detectives, he was certain that Judith had put something in his food. According to Iliar, Judith treated Lindsay's money as though it were her own. She kept receipts for her own groceries and car expenses and claimed them from Lindsay's account every month. This could be anything from $500 to $1,000. When the care facility that Lindsay had lived in for 20 years closed down, she was angry that Lindsay had to spend $17,000 from his trust to pay to live in the residential accommodation on Grano Street. Had he been on a pension, the government would have given him a place to live for free. Not only was there a buy-in cost, but there was a weekly cost of $60 as
现在与侦探交谈时，他确信朱迪丝在他的食物里放了东西。据伊利亚尔说，朱迪丝把林赛的钱当作她自己的钱。她保留了自己买杂货和汽车费用的收据，并每月从林赛的账户中报销。这可能是500到1000美元之间的任何金额。当林赛住了20年的护理机构关闭时，她很生气，因为林赛不得不从他的信托基金中拿出17000美元来支付住在格雷诺街的住宅设施的费用。如果他领养老金，政府会免费给他提供一个住处。不仅有买入成本，还有每周60美元的费用，
well. Everything Judith bought for Lindsay, from clothes to sweets, was purchased with his own money. Judith talked to Iliar about bringing Lindsay to live with her at Melton. She said the government would pay her $300 per week to look after him and she could use his money to buy her house from the housing commission. The only catch was, she wanted Iliar to do the actual caring for Lindsay. Judith did a test run and brought her brother home a couple of days before Christmas. But it didn't work. She returned him to Grano Street by Boxing Day. In that time, she used Lindsay's money to buy presents for her children. Detectives asked Iliar if Judith had been in the habit of washing her car after driving to Ararat
也是如此。朱迪丝为林赛买的一切，从衣服到糖果，都是用他自己的钱买的。朱迪丝和伊利亚尔谈过把林赛带到梅尔顿和她住在一起。她说政府每周会付给她300美元来照顾他，她可以用他的钱从住房委员会买下她的房子。唯一的条件是，她想让伊利亚尔来实际照顾林赛。朱迪丝做了一次试验，在圣诞节前几天把她哥哥带回了家。但这行不通。她在节礼日就把他送回了格雷诺街。在那段时间里，她用林赛的钱给她的孩子们买了礼物。侦探问伊利亚尔，朱迪丝是否有开车去阿拉拉特后洗车的习惯，
to visit her brother. Iliar had gone with Judith half a dozen times. She had never washed her car once. As for the Noctek, Iliar knew all about the syrup Judith gave her children at night. The last time he'd seen it happen was on the New Year's Eve just past. Iliar had arrived at Judith's house at 10pm so he wouldn't be alone for the occasion. The lights were on but her car wasn't in the driveway. He went inside only to find Judith's small children asleep in the house alone, with Judith nowhere to be seen. She returned home around 1am, saying she'd just popped out to play the pokies. It wasn't the first time something like this had happened. Iliar said, Judith gave the children syrup to make them sleep. I don't know what this syrup is called, but I saw her give it to them. If these revelations weren't significant enough,
去探望她的兄弟。伊利亚尔和朱迪丝一起去过六次。她一次也没洗过车。至于Noctek，伊利亚尔很清楚朱迪丝晚上给孩子们喝的糖浆。他最后一次看到这种情况是在刚过去的除夕夜。伊利亚尔晚上10点到达朱迪丝家，这样他就不会一个人过节了。灯亮着，但她的车不在车道上。他进去后发现朱迪丝的小孩独自在屋里睡觉，朱迪丝不见踪影。她凌晨1点左右回到家，说她只是出去玩老虎机了。这不是第一次发生这种事了。伊利亚尔说，朱迪丝给孩子们喝糖浆让他们睡觉。我不知道这种糖浆叫什么，但我看到她给他们喝。如果这些披露还不够重要，
Iliar then dropped another bombshell. He told detectives that Judith had illegally purchased a blank prescription pad for $100 and could write herself any prescription she wanted. Police spoke to Judith's eldest son, 24-year-old Greg, who confirmed that his mother had always spoken of Lindsay's money as being hers after he died. Greg had found out about Lindsay's death from a neighbour rather than his mother. He assumed she was too upset to call him. When he did speak to her, Judith allegedly told Greg that when she visited Lindsay on
伊利亚尔随后又投下了一枚重磅炸弹。他告诉侦探，朱迪丝非法购买了一本价值100美元的空白处方笺，可以给自己写任何她想要的处方。警方与朱迪丝的长子、24岁的格雷格谈话，他证实他的母亲在林赛死后一直说林赛的钱是她的。格雷格是从邻居那里而不是从他母亲那里得知林赛死讯的。他以为她太难过了，没法给他打电话。当他确实和她交谈时，据称朱迪丝告诉格雷格，当她在林赛去世那天去看望他时，
the day he died, she had taken him for a drive around the dirt roads of Ararat. At one point, she stopped so that Lindsay could relieve himself on the side of the road. Judith hadn't mentioned this when she gave her original account to the police. The detectives suspected she was trying to lay the groundwork for explaining why her tyre impressions were on down road. Greg was also candid about a phone call with his mother where she talked about washing her car. She apparently said to him, You know I always wash the car and under the car after I have been to see Lindsay. car and under the car after I have been to see Lindsay." Greg told the detectives,
她带他开车绕着阿拉拉特的土路转了一圈。有一次，她停下来让林赛在路边方便。朱迪丝在向警方提供最初的陈述时没有提到这一点。侦探们怀疑她是在为解释为什么她的轮胎印在路边做铺垫。格雷格还坦率地谈到了与母亲的一次通话，她在通话中谈到了洗车。她显然对他说：“你知道我每次去看完林赛后都会洗车和洗车底。”格雷格告诉侦探，
"...it was as though she was asking me to confirm this over the phone. I thought this was unusual. I know that she washes her car, but I have never seen her wash under the car." Greg said it was impossible that anyone could have stolen his mother's car to drive it to Ararat and kill Lindsay. He had recently fitted an alarm to it, which operated automatically once the key had been removed from the door. After four months of gathering evidence, detectives felt they finally had enough to present their case to the Department of Public Prosecutions. But they still faced a challenge. From a legal standpoint, because the cause of Lindsay Jellett's death couldn't be determined, it would be legally difficult to convict Judith Jen Giz of killing him.
“……就好像她在电话里让我确认这一点。我觉得这很不寻常。我知道她会洗车，但我从来没见过她洗车底。”格雷格说，不可能有人偷了他母亲的车开到阿拉拉特并杀害林赛。他最近给车装了一个警报器，一旦钥匙从门上拔出，它就会自动启动。经过四个月的证据收集，侦探们觉得他们终于有足够的证据向公诉部门提交案件了。但他们仍然面临挑战。从法律角度来看，由于林赛·杰莱特的死因无法确定，在法律上很难判定朱迪丝·根吉兹杀害了他。
As such, when Judith was charged with murder and the committal hearing went ahead in Ararat, the magistrate threw it out of court. Normally, a person goes through a committal hearing and then is sent to trial. But another option is for the Crown to present them directly to trial without testing the evidence at a committal hearing. After much discussion, this is what the Office of Public Prosecutions decided to do. Judith was recharged with murder and summoned to trial. murder and summoned to trial. However, in a major blow to the prosecution, the judge ruled the Noctek evidence as inadmissible. While Judith had purchased the Noctek on three separate occasions in 1989, he ruled that there was no evidence to suggest she was still in possession of it five
因此，当朱迪丝被控谋杀并在阿拉拉特进行预审听证会时，地方法官将其驳回。通常，一个人要经过预审听证会，然后被送去审判。但另一种选择是皇家检察署直接将他们提交审判，而不经过预审听证会测试证据。经过多次讨论，这就是公诉办公室决定采取的做法。朱迪丝被重新指控谋杀并被传唤受审。然而，对检方来说是一个重大打击的是，法官裁定Noctek的证据不可采信。虽然朱迪丝在1989年曾三次购买Noctek，但他裁定没有证据表明她在五年后仍然持有它，
years later, despite the fact that she had hundreds of bottles of medicine in her house from years earlier. The judge ruled that if the jury knew that Lindsay had therapeutic doses of Noctek in his system, they would assume that it was part of a plan to kill him. This, according to the judge, could not be established. The possibility couldn't be ruled out that Lindsay took the medication from somewhere and administered it to himself. Based on the evidence, the judge had no doubt that Lindsay was already dead when his sister allegedly ran him over. What was unclear was where and when his death had occurred. Judith's lawyers argued that Lindsay could have died following a seizure or from SUDEP. But as the prosecution pointed out, if Lindsay had died
尽管她家里有几年前留下的数百瓶药。法官裁定，如果陪审团知道林赛的系统中有治疗剂量的Noctek，他们会认为这是杀害他计划的一部分。据法官称，这一点无法确定。不能排除林赛从某处拿了药并自己服用的可能性。根据证据，法官毫不怀疑林赛在被他妹妹据称碾压时已经死亡。不清楚的是他的死亡地点和时间。朱迪丝的律师辩称，林赛可能是在癫痫发作后或因SUDEP死亡。但正如检方指出的那样，如果林赛是自然死亡，
from natural causes, why would Judith go to the trouble of dragging his body to the side of the road, running him over, fabricating a story and lying to the police. The only logical conclusion they argued was that Judith believed Lindsay was still alive at the time. Without knowing for sure how Lindsay had died, the judge ruled that the murder charge be thrown out in favour of a charge of attempted murder. This meant that if the jury were convinced by the evidence under the car and Judith's motive to inherit her brother's money, they only had one option – to convict Judith
为什么朱迪丝要费尽周折把他的尸体拖到路边，碾压他，编造故事并向警方撒谎？他们辩称，唯一的逻辑结论是朱迪丝认为林赛当时还活着。由于无法确定林赛是如何死亡的，法官裁定驳回谋杀指控，转而支持谋杀未遂指控。这意味着，如果陪审团被车下的证据和朱迪丝继承她兄弟钱财的动机所说服，他们只有一个选择——判定朱迪丝
of the attempted murder of a dead man. And that's what they did. Judith Genghis was declared guilty of attempted murder and sentenced to 10 years with a six-year non-parole period. Judith appealed against both conviction and sentence. Her lawyer argued that the judge should have thrown out the attempted murder charge since the only thing the Crown could prove Judith did was run Lindsay over, but he was clearly dead when this happened. In June 1997, three Supreme Court judges rejected Judith's appeal, with one concluding, quote, "...the deceased was vulnerable.
犯有谋杀死者未遂罪。他们就是这么做的。朱迪丝·根吉兹被判谋杀未遂罪名成立，判处10年监禁，其中6年不得假释。朱迪丝对定罪和判决都提出了上诉。她的律师辩称，法官应该驳回谋杀未遂指控，因为皇家检察署能证明朱迪丝做的唯一一件事就是碾压了林赛，但他发生这种情况时显然已经死了。1997年6月，三名最高法院法官驳回了朱迪丝的上诉，其中一人总结道，引用：“……死者是弱势群体。
He had been brain damaged as a young child. He trusted the applicant. She, however, being concerned that the fund invested on behalf of the deceased was dissipating steadily, was determined to obtain possession of it. The applicant was prepared to kill to satisfy her greed. She did everything possible to affect her end. The evidence is that had her brother not been dead when she drove her car over him, he would have died as a result. She has shown no remorse. Judith Genghis was released from jail in February 2002 after serving her minimum sentence. Two years later, an application was made to the Masters Fund that held Lindsay Jellett's money.
他小时候大脑受过损伤。他信任上诉人。然而，她担心代表死者投资的基金正在稳步流失，决心获得其所有权。上诉人为了满足贪婪不惜杀人。她尽了一切可能来实现她的目的。证据表明，如果她哥哥在她开车碾过他时还没死，他也会因此死亡。她没有表现出任何悔意。朱迪丝·根吉兹在服满最低刑期后于2002年2月出狱。两年后，有人向持有林赛·杰莱特钱财的信托基金提出了申请。
Surviving relatives agreed among themselves as to how the money would be divided. Who got what is sealed in confidential court records. When Judith was first being questioned about her brother's death, she told detectives she'd seen him talking to a woman about his recent winnings on the pokies. She'd framed it in a way that sounded somewhat sinister, when in reality the woman Lindsay was speaking to was the former employee of a local kiosk. With his love for biscuits and his addiction to cigarettes, Lindsay had been a frequent customer, and the woman liked him from the moment they met. He was always happy and very friendly.
幸存的亲属就如何分配这笔钱达成了一致。谁得到了什么被封存在机密的法庭记录中。当朱迪丝第一次被询问她兄弟的死因时，她告诉侦探，她看到他和一名女子谈论他最近在老虎机上的赢钱。她以一种听起来有些险恶的方式描述了这件事，而实际上林赛与之交谈的女子是当地一家售货亭的前员工。由于他喜欢饼干和对香烟的依赖，林赛经常光顾，那个女人从他们见面起就喜欢他。他总是很高兴，非常友好。
On the day Lindsay died, she had been in the main shopping centre of Ararat when she heard Lindsay call to her. They got chatting and he told her that he'd had the best day ever because he was out with his sister. Lindsay's gravestone says just one thing about him. Cherished twin brother of Judith. Judith passed away in 2017. She was buried alongside Lindsay, their shared gravestone declaring, MUSIC With the FIZ loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with FIZ. Switch today.
在林赛去世的那天，她正在阿拉拉特的主要购物中心，听到林赛叫她。他们聊了起来，他告诉她，他度过了有史以来最好的一天，因为他和他的妹妹在一起。林赛的墓碑上只写了一件事：朱迪丝挚爱的双胞胎兄弟。朱迪丝于2017年去世。她被安葬在林赛身边，他们共同的墓碑上写着：音乐。有了FIZ忠诚计划，您只需拥有移动套餐即可获得奖励。你知道，发短信之类的。如果您没有通过移动套餐获得额外数据和美元折扣等奖励，那么您就不是FIZ的用户。今天就切换吧。
Conditions apply. Details at FIZ.ca. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
适用条件。详情请见FIZ.ca。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。